quel est le quotidien d'un chercheur
comment obtenir un médicament
maryline moulin travaille sur une
maladie génétique rare qui touche les
muscles elle présentait sa formation et
son métier avec les élèves du lycée jean
rostand à mantes la jolie je m'intéresse
une maladie génétique qui touche le gène
de la sceller nos protéines cette
protéine est impliqué donc dans la
fonction du muscle elle intervient entre
deux organes importants dans le muscle
une galette qui va fournir de l'énergie
est l'autre qui va dire à la cellule qui
va falloir se contracter donc moi
j'étudie le rôle de cette protéine dans
cette coordination entre l'énergie est
l'action de se contracter maryline
moulin participe à 1000 chercheurs dans
les écoles organisé par l'afm téléthon
l'opération a pour but de susciter des
vocations c'est important pour nos
élèves je pense parce que ils ont pas
forcément accès dans leur entourage à
des personnes qui sont dans les
laboratoires les enseignants chercheurs
à des personnes peut-être même au centre
diplômés on a pas mal d'élèves on est
anciennement en zep aussi a donc avec
pas mal de statuts sociaux assez
compliqué en s'appuyant sur des exemples
concrets marilyn moulins étaient
également présentes pour montrer que la
recherche est accessible j'ai pas été
directement à l'université en disant je
veux être chercheur à la fin pour leur
montrer que bath est possible que ya des
passerelles et qu'on peut donc même
après avoir décidé de faire des études
courtes finalement se réorienter et
aboutir jusqu'à une thèse à dr a c'est
toujours intéressant d'en apprendre plus
surtout que moi en fait bas j'ai pris la
spécialité svt donc pour justement
continuer sur cette voie parce que j'ai
des projets pour finir pour aller en
staps et en stop on nous demande de
connaître surtout tout ce qu'il corps
humain dix établissements yvelinois ont
participé à cette nouvelle édition